[Musique]
voyageons un peu d'antan il ya quelques
mois avant même que l'om est ce le
détermine que l'humanité fait face cette
pandémie
elle a identifié l'émergence d'une info
démis en constatant que la
désinformation basé sur la kobe 19
balles atteignent des proportions
mondiales
on va se tourner vers notre cher
collaboratrice bouchra wathiq ça ne
bouge pas ces lieux alexis on l'a
souvent vu au cours des derniers mois il
ya plusieurs points en commun plusieurs
points convergents entre le mode de
propagation d'une fausse nouvelle
et le mode de propagation de virus oui
donc on peut étudier analyser comment
une fausse nouvelle se propage en
prenons la france nouvelle comme si
c'était un virus donc premièrement les
virus on sait ça se transmet souvent par
contact direct
dans le cas de la coved c'est des
gouttelettes et dans le cas d'une fausse
nouvelle mais ça va aussi par contact
direct donc par exemple les gens qui on
va l'envoyer sur les réseaux sociaux les
gens qui on voit le dire de bouche à
oreille et c'est comme ça que ça se
transmet souvent autres termes qui est
souvent utilisée dans le cas des virus
c'est le patient zéro
la première personne qui était porteuse
du virus est dans le camp des forces
nouvelles dont on peut aussi considérer
qu'un patient zéro qui est souvent la
personne qui a inventé la fausse
information qui est la première personne
qui a transmis la fausse photo et dans
les deux camps dans le cas des virus
comment que des forces nouvelles c'est
très difficile de retracer le patient
zéro et on a aussi des supers
propagateurs de virus donc on l'a vu
dans le cas de la coved parfois une
seule personne pouvait en allant dans un
lieu public infecter des dizaines et des
dizaines de gens et d'alcool et france
nouvelle mais on peut considérer que les
super propagateur ça a été les
influenceurs les vedettes qui avaient
énormément d'abonnés les gens sur
youtube qui pouvaient en quelques
instants
transmettre la fausse nouvelle à des
centaines voire des milliers de gens en
même temps c'est fou le nombre de
parallèle qu on peut tracer entre les
deux et ce n'est pas tout parce qu'on
sait qu'on peut se protéger d'un virus
est ce qu'on peut faire la même chose
avec une fausse nouvelle
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que oui on
peut se protéger on peut arrêter la
propagation comme on peut le faire avec
un virus
donc premièrement pour les virus dans le
kodak au vide on privilégie la
distanciation physique les masques pour
éviter de transmettre le virus si on en
est porteur et dans le cas des fausses
nouvelles baies si on est porteur entre
guillemets de la fausse nouvelle si on
le reçu on peut éviter la transmettre
simplement on ne la partageant pas il ya
aussi dans le cas de certains virus des
remèdes des médicaments qui permettent
de guérir une fois qu'on est infecté
dans le cas des fausses nouvelles on
peut faire le parallèle avec les
articles de vérification de fait comme
ce qui est fait par les décrypteurs nos
lecteurs effectivement
donc si on les infectés par la force
nouvelle si on y ont cru en fait on peut
en lisant un article qui rectifie les
faits mais corriger notre notre
perception de l'information et
finalement on attend dans le cas de la
coved le fameux vaccin qui va faire en
sorte que même si on est exposé au virus
on ne sera pas infecté et dans le cas de
la désinformation on peut parler de
vaccins en termes d'éducation
donc si on apprend à développer son
esprit critique qu'on apprend à douter
mais on peut être en quelque sorte
inoculé contre la désinformation
donc ne même pas y croire parce qu'on
saura comment faire nous mêmes les
vérifications
on dit souvent que c'est un des
meilleurs remèdes une des meilleures
façons plutôt de prévenir la
désinformation il y en a plusieurs qui
milite pour davantage de pédagogie en ce
sens là merci beaucoup mouchoirs merci à
une prochaine
salut